retenidos por las tropas rusas por
supuestamente pasar información a las
tropas ucranianas sobre la actividad de
los militares del kremlin es la historia
de volodymyr coprumh y julia y vánnikova
voluntarios de la cruz roja que fueron
detenidos mientras ayudaban a la
evacuación de civiles desde las
localidades cercanas a kiev que
estuvieron en la primera línea del
frente durante el mes de marzo ambos
fueron liberados el 9 de abril en un
intercambio de prisioneros y relatan que
durante las tres semanas que estuvieron
bajo cautiverio en una fábrica
recibieron palizas y descargas con
pistolas eléctricas
primero tuve que desvestir me estaba
desnuda luego me sacaron fotos de mis
cicatrices tengo unas cuantas las
describieron después me echaron agua me
golpearon los primeros siete días los
pasé en el hospital militar con tres
soldados dos de ellos ni siquiera sé si
siguen vivos nos daban un litro y medio
de agua al día que no bebíamos sino que
se lo dábamos a los dos militares
para volodymyr lo más cruel fue que las
tropas rusas ni siquiera respetaron su
labor como voluntarios humanitarios de
cruz roja
me detuvieron me taparon los ojos y
luego me envolvieron las manos con cinta
como está escucho mucho pero como un
terrorista
luego me trasladaron aquí de pizzas
durante el interrogatorio y voces de los
compañeros de cautiverio había otras
cuatro personas allí cuando me
detuvieron llevaba el uniforme la cruz
roja el uniforme oficial pero no les
importó que llevara el chaleco antibalas
y el uniforme esa gente no saben lo que
la civilización
le pidió
aunque los testimonios de estos
voluntarios ucranianos no fueron
confirmados ni por el kremlin ni por el
ministerio de defensa ruso durante la
ofensiva rusa en ucrania ambas partes se
han acusado mutuamente de violar los
convenios de ginebra que velan por la
protección de los civiles